hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i'm going to teach you a trick to
multiply two numbers very quickly in
your head if the two numbers have a
special property
what you want to look for is you want to
see if the two numbers have units digits
which add up to 10
and they have the tens digit which is
the same
so this sounds kind of complicated but
just won't go through some of the
examples it'll actually be a pretty
impressive trick
when you can pull it off randomly
so let's do 83 times 87
this multiplication problem works
because 3 plus 7 is 10
and the tens digit of 8 is the same
between the two numbers
so the trick you want to do
the first step is you multiply the units
digits together
which is 3 times 7 which gets 21.
the second step is you take the tens
digit and multiply it by one more than
itself
in this problem the tens digit is eight
so we take eight times one more than
itself nine
and that gives us seventy-two
and that's our answer eighty-three times
eighty-seven is seventy-two twenty-one
to do another example thirty-two times
thirty-eight
we multiply the units digits together
two times eight is sixteen
then we take the tens digit of three and
multiply it by one more than itself four
to get twelve
so thirty two times thirty eight is
twelve sixteen
if we wanna do ninety-one times
ninety-nine
we multiply the units digits together
and one times nine is nine
but we make a small adjustment and write
it as a two digit answer
we then continue and we multiply the
tens digit by one more than itself so
nine times ten is ninety
and that gets us our answer
of ninety oh nine
let's say we wanna do forty five times
forty five
this multiplication problem works
because 5 plus 5 is 10 and the tens
digits are the same
so our first step we multiply the units
digits 5 times 5 is 25
then we take the ten's digit of four and
multiply it by one more than itself to
get 20.
some of you will notice this is actually
this problem we've done
is actually a special case of a previous
video i made called squaring a number
that ends in five
we can also extend this to three digit
numbers let's say we want to do 124
times 126.
we multiplied the units digits of 4
times 6 to get 24
and now we multiply the rest of the
digits so we have 12 in both numbers and
we need to multiply it by 12 plus 1 13.
some of you will know what this is
others of you will know that 12 times 13
is 156 because it's on the cover of my
book multiplying numbers by lines
but quite amazingly
this procedure will work even for three
digit numbers
so why is this going to work i'm going
to give you a simple proof
when we multiply two digits where the
tens digit are the same
and the units digits add up to 10
this is the same as multiplying 10x plus
y
times 10x
plus 10 minus y
the green y and 10 minus y add up to 10
and the 10x is the same in both
quantities that's our tens digit
so we're going to go through some
algebra we first expand out the product
and we end up with several terms four
terms
we then expand out
further
and now we can see there's some
cancellation that can be done the 10xy
minus 10xy cancels out
so we have 100x squared plus 100x
plus 10 minus y times y
and that brings us to our answer when we
factor out the 100x we get 100x times x
plus 1
plus
10 minus y times y
so the quantity in green
this is multiplying the units digits
together
y and 10 minus y
and the quantity in black is multiplying
x times x plus one so that's where we
get our rule
i hope you liked this video
please subscribe to my channel i make
videos on math and game theory you can
also catch me on my blog mind your
decisions on twitter at preshtalwalker
or get my books at amazon